[Music]
chapel hill some faculty there at unc
chapel hill are criticizing their own
university after june
journalist nicole hannah jones announced
exclusively right here on cbs this
morning that she is declining a tenured
position there
she told gail yesterday she accepted a
position instead at howard university
after weeks of controversy all that
comes after the unc
board of trustees delayed its decision
to grant her tenure
some faculty at unc's journalism school
wrote a public
letter yesterday saying the way the
university treated her
was racist we spoke to a board member
about all of this and nikki batista is
here with more nikki good morning to you
good morning everyone in that public
letter faculty members also said unc's
treatment of the pulitzer prize-winning
journalist
was humiliating inappropriate and unjust
after hannah jones announcement we took
a look at the fallout for unc
very difficult decision not a decision i
wanted to make
a difficult decision that unc dean susan
king says she also wishes nicole hannah
jones
didn't have to make the head of chapel
hills journalism school was one of
hannah jones fiercest advocates
nicole was going to be what i felt
perhaps my most important legacy last
year hannah jones was appointed as the
night chair of race and investigative
journalism
the controversy began after it became
public
that the position was offered with a
five-year contract
instead of tenure this was a position
that since the 1980s
came with tenure the night chairs are
designed for professional journalists
who have been working in the field to
come into academia and every other chair
before me
who also happened to be white received
that position with tenure
i it has never been denied no one had
never been denied tenure before
exactly after public outcry and student
protests
the board of trustees took up a vote
last week offering hannah jones
their alumni tenure but she ultimately
decided
not to accept it why do you suppose they
didn't
right away offer you tenure what do you
think the reason is
i mean what has been reported is that
there was a great deal of political
interference
by conservatives who don't like the work
that i've done particularly the 1619
project hannah jones 1619 project aimed
to re-examine
american slavery and its impact on
society policies and the legal system
it earned her journalism's highest honor
the pulitzer prize
do you think this had anything to do
with
ms hannah jones 16 19 project i'm sure
it had some impact
the project has long been criticized by
republicans
including former president donald trump
this project
rewrites american history to teach our
children
that we were founded on the principle of
oppression
not freedom nothing could be further
from the truth
there are 13 members of unc's board of
trustees
who voted on hannah jones tenure four of
them are appointed by the
republican-controlled state house and
senate
cbs news spoke to board of trustees
member ralph meekins who says he thinks
it was poor communication not politics
that was to blame for hannah jones not
initially being offered tenure
he said the chair of the committee
reviewing hannah jones tenure
application
had some questions back in january which
was typical in the review process
when he says they didn't hear back
regarding those questions
the process stalled meekins also told us
he doesn't think it was about the
content or
truthfulness of the 1619 project which
he called
impactful work adding he admires hannah
jones and wishes she was coming to unc
hannah jones denies that anyone at unc
requested
additional information for her tenure
application
janae nelson with the naacp legal
defense and educational fund
is hannah jones legal counsel if ms anna
jones went forward with a lawsuit what
would the grounds of the lawsuit
be so there are several but they are
rooted in
violations of the first amendment and
also
race discrimination gender
discrimination and the intersection of
both
there's also a state law in north
carolina that prohibits employment
discrimination
and political influence on state
decisions
that academic freedom on campus has been
in trouble for quite some time
greg lukianov is the president and ceo
of the foundation for individual rights
and education
his organization was one of the first to
criticize hannah jones
not getting tenure my hope is what will
come out of this case
is a greater awareness of the threat to
academic freedom
as for dean king she says she's ready to
help unc
journalism students heal while using
hannah jones as an example
of what they can achieve she is not just
a great journalist
she's a once in a generation journalist
hannah jones told us the university's
provost and chancellor never reached out
during the process
in a statement the chancellor said he is
disappointed that hannah jones will not
be coming to chapel hill
and that he is committed to making unc a
more welcoming
place and you can't help but wonder that
journalism students for years to come
are probably going to be learning about
this situation oh they absolutely will
and i think her
point in that letter is that this isn't
just her fighting for herself but on
behalf of the many people
whose opportunities are stifled because
there are certain people that don't want
certain people in these institutions
and for sure the students at howard
university are lucky they will have her
as a teacher yeah yeah pretty remarkable
a lot of people are also living
vicariously through her
being able to say wow someone said i
don't want this job i got a better job
take that and she had a lot of options
yeah a lot of people are good
all right nicky thank you